all right i haven't done like a
comprehensive
where we are in the pandemic type update
for some time
but it is time to do it a lot of things
have changed and there is much to
discuss
so to begin with we're starting to see
some
really significant improvements taking
place vaccines are being rolled out more
significantly
i know about the variants i know about
the so-called mutant
strains and i will talk about them i'm
not ignoring them i'm aware of them
i have the latest information as to how
they will affect
the vaccination program if this or if
that so i'm not ignoring that just give
me five minutes to get to it i know that
it's what
uh a lot of folks have been focused in
on but let's dive right in so first of
all
cases just the top line case number back
in december
i predicted cases would peak permanently
around january 10th to 15th now how did
i do this
am i an epidemiologist no am i a public
health expert no
was i special in predicting this no do i
want a
pat on the back yes but not for this
um a combination of uh
experts were pointing out that given
the winter peak and vaccines being
rolled out
and the holiday effect we were likely to
see
a peak sometime around the middle of
january
and case in point case that's a pun
uh the peak for the seven-day case
average
came on january 11th when the united
states hit an
average of 255 000 cases per day
since then the number of cases has
dropped
by more than 40 percent to a seven day
case average
of 147 000 cases so the bad news is
147 000 new cases a day is
insane it's tragic it's a disaster being
down
close to 50 in new cases per day
in just a three week period that is
absolutely fantastic and i expect that
by the end of the week we will be down
that full
50 now uh cases is one thing
but what about deaths uh we also had
reason to believe
that the death peak would come three
or four weeks after the case peak why
did we have reason to believe that well
we know from the last year of this
pandemic that deaths lag cases by three
to four weeks
and indeed the seven day rolling average
of deaths plateaued
over the last seven to ten days and
hopefully hopefully we'll be on its way
down soon i had thought yesterday or
today would be the peak it turns out
we've had sort of a plateau
let's hope that those death numbers go
down from here
still and i want to be clear that even
as we see things improve
we don't want to forget that thousands
of people have been dying in the united
states
every day 4 000 down to 3 000 is still
insane it's still a 911 every single day
and there is a very long way to go but
the good news
is that the numbers are doing what we
thought they would in early december
based on a lot of different factors
including vaccination
let's now talk about that officially the
u.s has seen
about 27 million coronavirus cases
and the u.s has now administered not
distributed
administered 33 million vaccine doses
into the arms of folks so we now have
officially more doses than
number of cases that's a nice milestone
now if you remember my interview with dr
eric topple a couple of weeks ago our
best guess right now
is that the real number of cases when
you consider that many people never get
tested because they're asymptomatic or
they have mild symptoms and just never
go and get a test the real number of
cases is believed to be somewhere
between two and three times the official
number
but still it's a nice thing to be able
to say we've now given doses
we've given significantly more doses
than the number of total cases
as of right now as of this morning eight
percent of the u.s population has
received at least one dose
and about two percent of the u.s
population has received
both doses remember with the pfizer
vaccine
you have 21 days between dose one and
two
with the moderna vaccine you have 28
days between dose one and two
you are not considered to be at maximum
immunity potential and remember
not everybody develops immunity but
close to 95
do you're not considered to have
completed the full course
of vaccination and antibody generation
um until 7 to 14 days after your
second dose what we know is that these
vaccines are working
really well infections and
hospitalizations
are down among those first vaccinated
this
includes health care workers and nursing
home residents
the two vaccines in play are pfizer and
moderna
and although the rollout was a little
bit slower than we would have hoped they
are accelerating dramatically
pfizer going to bring in additional
manufacturers a lot is happening there
we also have a third vaccine and more
but most imminently we have the johnson
and johnson vaccine
imminently to be submitted for approval
and within a couple of weeks after that
hopefully emergency use authorization
that's a one-shot
vaccine now let's talk about the mutants
the variants uh we have the uk variant
the brazilian variant and the south
african variant
the concern being vaccines are or
might be less effective against those
variants some people already going as
far as to say they won't work
the vaccination program is in vain we're
vaccinating against the strain
that is not even the strain okay let's
stop
let's sort of break it down a little bit
into its component parts because much of
what
we are being told so far is not true
first of all
the rate at which these uh i don't want
to call them primary yeah i guess we
could call them primary
variants or or significant variants are
mutating is exactly as expected for this
type of virus nothing is happening that
was
not predictable in terms of these types
of viruses and mutation that's number
one
number two uh the as close as we can
currently get
to a reality-based assessment of the
effectiveness of vaccines
on the variants is as follows the two
vaccines
currently in use pfizer and moderna in
the united states
appear to be essentially as effective
against the uk
variant and the brazilian variant as
they are
against the the sort of uh main strain
as we might know it
it is true that the antibodies
generated by these vaccines appear to be
less effective against the south african
variant
that doesn't mean that they don't still
generate enough antibodies
to be immune to for most people against
the south african variant and what i
mean by that is as follows
when you vaccinate people they generate
antibodies on a curve
and you know we we talk about it's 95
percent
effective what we mean by that is five
percent of people who get the vaccine
don't generate enough antibodies for
immunity now you might still generate
enough
to avoid a hospitalization or a death
but five percent don't generate enough
antibodies for immunity to the primary
strain
but you have a curve so you might have
just assigned fake numbers to it 95
percent of people generate at least
a 100 level of antibodies 90
generate at least 200 uh level of
antibodies
80 percent are at the thousand level so
on and so forth
while it appears to be true that the
antibodies generated
are less effective against the south
african variant
it may still be effective enough for
most people to be immune
imagine that the antibodies generated
are a thousand level uh and only
a hundred of them are effective against
the south african variant well
if the threshold to be immune is only 95
then you're still okay and i hope i'm
being clear about that
so we still are gathering information
about this
the idea that the vaccines don't work
against the variants
so far is not based in fact or science
it's not yet been demonstrated and
importantly this is a race against the
variants the variants are a reason to
vaccinate as quickly as possible
not to delay vaccination viruses mutate
by spreading
the more people that vaccinate more
quickly we slow the spread of the
variance
and prevent more people from getting
that variant which
may be less controlled by the vaccines
we currently have
moderna and pfizer both working on a
sort of modified booster in case it is
necessary
for some period down the road could be
eight or twelve months from now or
maybe even longer now as i said on the
bonus show
i was on a wait list for leftover doses
a lot of
of hospitals and vaccination facilities
are having issues where because there's
multiple doses in a vial
you might get to the end of the day and
have leftover doses
and most hospitals have some kind of
on-call
list i have a friend who works at a
hospital i said put me on the list i
will
give me 30 minutes notice and i will
show up uh we don't you know
she doesn't want any doses going to
waste and neither do i
um i was able over the weekend to get
the first dose
of the moderna vaccine i had more arm
pain
being a lefty i got it in my right arm
more arm pain
than for any vaccine i've had in my life
i had a fever and flu-like symptoms for
about 24-30 hours
i spent saturday in bed i am now
feeling fine and i'm ready and waiting
for my second dose
in a few weeks now one last thing i want
to talk about
there are more and more articles being
written
expressing concern that these vaccines
are being undersold
and they're being undersold when you
hear cautious public health experts say
things like
even after vaccinated you still should
social distance and wear masks and avoid
indoor crowds and all of this different
stuff
and i think it's important to understand
that
until we reach a level approaching herd
immunity
we all still need to continue taking a
number of the precautions that
many of us have been taking but we don't
want to undersell the importance of the
vaccine
because then you're going to see a lot
of people say what they are saying now
which is
even if i get the vaccine nothing
changes well then i'm just not going to
get the vaccine
uh the truth is that these vaccines
particularly pfizer and moderna are
almost 100 effective at preventing death
or even serious covid
that is a huge game changer while it has
not yet been confirmed
that the the vaccinated individuals
spread the disease to a significantly
lesser degree
that's what would be expected and that's
usually how vaccines work so i am a
little worried about the degree to which
the vaccines are undersold
as i said on the bonus show and as i've
spoken about with you know public health
officials and
epidemiologists who are speaking not for
the media but just kind of between
people
in six weeks in eight weeks
a group of four or six vaccinated people
who work from home
are able to be together with extremely
low risk it is not zero nothing is ever
zero
but these vaccines are game changers and
we want to make sure we are not
underselling them and we continue
vaccinating as quickly as possible i get
people are being cautious
but if you we start telling people even
with vaccination you still have to
social distance and wear masks
indefinitely
a lot of people will say well i'm going
to opt out and we don't want that
send me your thoughts i am on twitter at
deepakman
this is good news notice i didn't
mention trump or biden in this entire
segment this is an analysis of the data
and the science of what is going on this
is not a political statement
a political segment of any kind let me
know your thoughts i'm on twitter at
deepakman
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors
s h masks snh masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other
protective gear for covid19 and they're
giving my audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell and that's actually
why i reached out to them
about being a sponsor i've tried tons of
different face masks this year like many
of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap they
also have disposable cloth masks which
are really comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers
and all of their prices are very
reasonable i also love
snh masks because they've donated over
60
000 masks to healthcare institutions
they're an
excellent company shipping is just five
bucks and shipping is
free on orders over a hundred and fifty
dollars you can get there by going to
davidpakman.com slash mask the link is
under this video
and you can save 20 on everything in
their store when you use the coupon code
david